a tragic series of events in Hawaii
ended with two police officers shot dead
and parts of a neighborhood in flames
the huge fires were seen burning in the
trendy Waikiki Beach area of Honolulu
yesterday three people are still missing
including the alleged gunman Jamie
yuccas has the story
a massive response by police and
firefighters Sunday morning started with
a 9-1-1 call from a woman in this
affluent Honolulu neighborhood the
initial responding officer found a
female who had been stabbed in the leg
court records show she was trying to
evict the suspect Gerry Hanul shortly
thereafter we heard shots being fired
the suspect opened fire on officers
approaching the house killing officer
Tiffany and Rica's Callie Kay Kalama was
among a second group of responding
officers he was also shot and killed
Hanul whom neighbors described as
mentally disturbed has a history of
run-ins with police this body cam video
from last year shows him being cited for
making false 911 calls police sources
say he set fire to the house he and two
women believed to have been inside are
still unaccounted for
a total of seven homes were destroyed we
will continue to search for Hanul until
we confirm that his remains are
recovered processing the crime scene
could take several more days for CBS
this morning I'm Jamie yuccas